après un tour de france d'une durée de
deux mois et demi 6 kg au fait étape
avec ses deux cabines dans les rues
piétonnes de la zone commerciale de
l'espace saint quentin situe au signifie
foetus en finnois le fondateur est parti
de cette idée pour lancer sa start up
est ce que je peux ramener les gens dans
certaines études quand on était bébé est
donc toute l'idée en fait du concept
c'est de vous ramener en fait dans la
plénitude donc on va vous déjà vous
remettre dans la position foetale parce
que quand vous dormez la nuit
la plupart du temps vous dormez en fait
en position foetale et puis après il ya
tout un tas de choses à bord d'un siège
chauffer cette jeune femme vient de
vivre une balade en forêt s'est appuyé
sur mal de points de tension est ce une
machine assez intelligente qui fait un
calcul est assez spectaculaire du cordes
c'est un siège massant qui nous ramène
un petit peu un état d'hypnose mélange
d'hypnose et une méditation
cette femme est sophrologue et à tester
la cabine sitio la séance dure une
dizaine de minutes
on nous casse les pieds éléments en plus
parce qu'un massage plutôt des épaules
enfin on peut avoir ce genre de choses
avec effectivement delà de la musique
douce et puis une voix qui peut nous
emporter dans d'autres espaces pour
permettre un autre guinéen lâcher prise
c'est avec un tour de france que si kyo
s'est fait connaître dans plus de quinze
villes cette start up propose un
financement participatif
les gens vont être intéressés au chiffre
d'affaires pendant cinq ans ils vont
pouvoir récupérer jusqu'à trois fois la
mise et l'idée en fait c'est qu'on a mis
un ticket d'entrée qui est le plus bas
possible c'est à partir de 50 euros si
kyo a collecté 25 1850 euros avec ce
tour de france
il fait étape à l'espace 50 ans jusqu'au
samedi 21 décembre